you look like Beckham and we're out good
going back to the clothes I see
telekinesis these magnets and actually
you're lame you're lame sorry that was
too loud your leg sorry for yelling you
look like a ladies college basketball
coach standing you paddle really hurt
you
professor Eck's what is that it's a job
and a letter you might as well be
plumber T Glover T you know your real
strong when your greatest weakness are
the stairs or deep sand that's hilarious
how's your 900 number mr. psychic I have
the answer call me now Miss Cleo
reference yeah you know who she is right
I do I'm over 40 everyone at home is
like white what I do was that I control
the power of magnets yes I get it
everyone gets it great
the cool thing also is that the word
neato is in my name magneto people like
that you think people like that your
name is the word neato it's like to
litigate about Mag terrific damn it damn
it I wonder if it's too late to change
my business cards you should fear me
Charles oh I do I don't stand a chance
against you in a third grade science
fair can a lemon ignite a light bulb
turns out yes really
ha ha ha what are we doing here let's go
into business
you